à
qu'est-ce qui s'attirent tally c'est ma
mère qui appelle ouais je l'appellerai
entre toi qui nous donne pas de petits
enfants si tu as envie de te caser j'ai
plein de cuisine je vais connaît déjà et
sont charmantes peut-être que quand je
serai pas ces chaînes salue ce côté
laissé aussi tient des croquettes inglès
des joujoux face et sont traités les
youtube de poids tant mieux pour lui que
maman capable et ton père voulait que ce
soit toi qui gardent ou chill adoptés
dans un refuge et ils disaient que cela
faisait presque comme si le 1er août
chypre a fini je regrette je te jure que
je peux pas chaud boulot constamment et
je débute je suis encore en train de
faire mes preuves moment je tends prise
comme tu va l'adorer
non non non j'en doute
[Musique]
ça va bien se passer laura et m'a dit en
retard pour le boulot squat on est un
cas d'extrême urgence ici trois hommes
au volant d'une seule balle crise
attentes a dit une super bonne glisse
tu vois je les prend en chasse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé est temps qu
on y est
pourquoi y at-il un chien dans mon
bureau alors ça c'est une longue
histoire mais je sais pas ce qu'il a il
est intenable je sais plus quoi faire
elle est peut-être quelqu'un qui
pourrait t'aider
eric artz te présente ce côté je vais
laisser discuter si tu peux faire quoi
que ce soit je commence à désespérer le
truc c'est qu'il ait pas dresser au
assis couché c'est bien one piece tient
bien avec tout le monde sauf avec moi
[Musique]
elle a écrit avant de quitter mon cher
ce motif c'est que tu penses ne pas
vouloir d'un chien
et tous les gens auxquels je tiens le
plus je les connais grâce à un chien
[Musique]
ocz a peut-être vu des choses que tu
n'as pas
[Musique]
c'est une surprise au travail sortez moi
ce chiffre d'ici ces chiens est une
véritable catastrophe au but il vérifie
que la fontaine n'a pas été contaminé on
s'investit à fond dans le dressage de
route
il s'améliore de jour en jour
merci où tu t'es super
ce
je suis vraiment désolé je suis désolé
parce qu'il est à toi
malheureusement
[Musique]